Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Look who I met randomly in Apex.
That's our story, right?
Tenjin, that's...
Say something, Tenjin!
Come on!
Who is this man?
He's fucking old, that's who.
Nice to meet you.
My name is Tenjin.
Fuck off!
I met Doki randomly in a lobby.
Nice to meet you, Tenjin.
Hey, Tenjin's chat!
Fuck off!
Yeah, yeah, we met randomly in a pubs match in Apex.
And I was like, whoa, dude, you should be a streamer.
And so I did!
Yeah!
I started this man's career.
Hell yeah!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
My stomach hurts.
Are you okay?
I've been trying to poop, it doesn't come out.
Oh yeah, he's been having like digestive issues.
Well, to be fair, there's been a lot of issues, but...
What issues?
You've been... what do you mean?
You're always sick!
What the fuck do you mean?
You're always fucking sick.
What do you mean?
What do you know about me?
We just met.
Oh, I mean like today you were telling me...
Okay, that's a lie because you called me out on stream.
Like that's a...
That's a fucking lie!
You literally called me out on stream!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
A few days ago, I was lurking and he called me out.
Yeah?
What's your excuse?
No, that didn't happen.
That didn't happen.
Oh yeah, yeah, that fucking thing... you do know people clipped us, you know?
It was fucking...
Whoa, I got clipped?
No way!
Yeah, you got fucking clipped!
I'm nobody!
I was fucking lurking.
Bro, I... oh, by the way, by the way, Tenjin, I told them... you remember that... remember that Tarkov story you told me?
The one where you... like... the one where you spent money on Tarkov after the whole scam thing because it was 80% off?
It was 50% off, though.
It was 50%... yeah, yeah, they... like, I told that story...
Yeah, but it was 50% off, though.
I told that story, but I didn't mention, like, who it was.
It was this man.
Yeah, but it was 50% off.
They literally just got out of a scam!
Yo, I'm blind.
You're blind.
Was it worth it?
No.
What?
I thought it was 80%.
It was actually 50%.
It was not.
If it was 80%, then it would've been worth it, but, like, you know...
It definitely would be.
Yes.
Yeah, it was 80%.
Anyway, guys... guys, someone quick refund him that money right now.
Someone refund him that money.
Hell, I'm about to get reimbursed.
No way.
Reimbursed.
Time to ask Steam for a refund real quick.
I can't aim.
Oh, nah, this thing is not tough.
Okay, I'm good.
Alright.
I'm dead.
Are you dead already?
We literally just... Oh my god, we literally just started...
Wait, do we have a new castle?
Wait, there's a new castle here.
Yeah, there's everyone here.
Wait, no, there's literally a new castle thing here.
That means there's a... Is there a team here?
Yeah, no, the enemy has a new castle.
Oh, oh, okay, okay, okay.
That's fine.
Whoa!
Are we getting... run out?
Yeah, we're getting...
No, we're not.
I knocked one.
Our teammate's dead.
Am I left?
Oh, he's so low!
Yeah, he's dead.
He's dead.
Yippee!
Yeah!
Nice.
Our teammate's dog shit.
Alright, so what have you been playing?
Where have you been... Oh, what the fuck?
Whoa!
How is he dead again?
Got you?
I got you.
Are you good?
Oh, you are not good.
You are not good.
I am not.
How?
I am still.
Oh my god, he's... Holy shit!
I'm fucking...
Bro!
Okay, I'm definitely lagging.
Yeah, well, you insisted playing here.
Yeah, yeah, okay, look.
Okay, look, it'll be fine.
It'll be fine.
I just... I hit like seven bullets and none of them registered.
I just need you to know that.
Oh, shit.
What's the chat?
How's the volume for you?
Oh, I'm using a Tengen now.
How is that?
Is that okay?
How's my volume on Tengen stream too?
You'll be fine.
What do you mean?
I put you on Compressor.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, so what have you been playing recently, Tengen?
I know you've been playing that finals game because...
For just the tournament.
Uh-huh, even though it's just for tournament.
Yeah.
But like... What did I play?
Yeah, what have you been playing?
Look, we've been having a rut, okay, guys?
That's a good question.
We have like zero FPS games to play these days.
I have... It is a hard time for FPS games.
Yeah, it's a hard time for us.
I like how someone said Tengen life alert fun, but then super chatted to me.
Thank you, man.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure Tengen gets it.
What?
Nah.
Oh, wait.
Have you tried X-Defiant yet?
Um... My friend's been trying to convince me to play, actually.
The good part is that there's no skill-based matchmaking.
Yeah, that's what I heard.
And it's like Overwatch and Call of Duty at the same time.
But I just don't like the pace.
How do you not like the pace if you've never played it yet?
I played the close beta.
Oh, yeah, you got into beta?
Oh, okay.
You think it's better than the beta?
I got into it twice.
I felt... I don't know.
Is it just me that I haven't been touching that game in a while?
Yeah.
It's like, it feels slower for some reason.
Or am I just... thinking?
I don't know.
I haven't tried it yet.
Where are you?
Where are you shooting?
Oh, my god.
You're literally on the tree!
Bro, I'm blind!
You're literally right in front of us, Tengen.
What the fuck?
That's why you're old.
I'm not old.
Yes, you are.
Why do you have white hair?
You.
Okay.
The stress from me.
We met, like, today.
What are you...
Yeah.
It took me two hours.
It took you two hours to have white hair?
Oh, my gosh.
What the fuck?
Oh, that's their whole team!
You can 1v3 that.
Hell!
What does that mean?
You're Tengen.
That's what I mean.
You'll be fine, right?
Yeah, see?
Wait, where's his teammate?
Nice.
Nice, man.
That is a long finish.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Bro took everything.
I killed him.
Bro, like, what the fuck's wrong with him?
Bro, I know, right?
This is why.
He took everything.
This is why, chat.
This is why.
This is why you have white hair.
I can't believe that man would do that.
I haven't even debuted in just a second.
I'm hurting.
I'm getting white here.
We almost leaked his new...
It was close.
We almost leaked it.
You know, if he had all his stuff, he would have...
Gorillas.
Yeah, he would have gorilla debuted.
And I was like, do it.
He was like, shit-ass, and I was a bad influence.
I was like, you shit.
A bad idea is still an idea.
I mean, it would have been pretty cool.
It would have been funny.
I would have thought it would have been funny.
Why not?
Because you're like... it would be just be like... like first stream.
That's not like the fucking finals.
I like how your first stream, like back was the finals.
Like just some random tournament.
Yeah.
That was like...
Hi, I'm back.
I'm playing tournament now.
Yeah, yeah.
You're like, I'm back.
By the way, this is a tournament stream.
Dude, you wanna know what happened?
What?
Thing is, a friend of mine got like invited to a tournament.
Yeah.
And he was told like, hey, you should invite two more guys.
You're in.
Something like that.
It was like five minutes from the announcement.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I was registered without even asked.
Two of us, me including the other teammate, was registered without being asked.
Oh, you were... they just registered you?
Knowing that we'd say yes.
They were just like, whatever, whatever.
Ten just gonna say yes anyway.
Crazy.
This guy.
Yeah.
So that means I can... Oh yeah, but yeah, I told him.
I told him like you were like one of the first subs for that Nokia tournament.
And then my chat, my chat said you got region locked in the IRL.
He actually got region locked IRL.
Do not, do not send stuff from international shipping to Indonesia.
Believe.
They're like, yeah, they're like, yeah, we don't know if he's gonna get in in time because of customs.
There's people in front of us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, someone's in front of us.
Yeah, wait, there's someone below?
What the fuck?
Someone's in front of you.
Yeah, what is he doing here?
Oh my God, where did this guy come from?
I thought it was like our decoy just now for some reason.
I was like, that had to be a decoy.
That was a chat.
I didn't see if you guys think if Tenjin's sound is okay.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, teammates over there.
They went over there.
Does this hit?
No, it doesn't hit.
Okay, I'm just gonna get closer.
It's okay.
They can't drop down now.
All right.
All right, I'll wait.
Okay, I'm heading up.
They ran.
Wait, no, they did.
On me?
Oh shit.
Hey, I got shot from behind.
It's okay.
I'm just gonna walk back.
Wait, I'm so safe.
I'm so safe.
Trust, trust, trust, trust.
Uh-huh.
Trust, trust, trust, trust, trust, trust.
Yeah, see, I told you.
Nice.
Always believe in me.
Oh.
Okay, I'm Phoenix Kidd.
Let me know if they're pushing up.
I'm Phoenix Kidd.
Let me know.
Okay, that is...
Oh, okay.
We're dead.
No, we're not.
Shit.
We're dead.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
Shoot the thing.
Oh, my God, shoot the thing.
Oh, God.
Oh.
Nexus.
No.
Oh, shit.
What?
My...
What's wrong with my E?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, my God.
Mirage, please res me.
Mirage!
No!
You killed me, Mirage!
Okay, I'm Mirage.
Mirage.
This just fucking sucks.
I hate him.
I hate our Mirage.
Our Mirage is fucking terrible.
Wait, there's different teams?
Oh no.
No, no, no, no, no!
Nooooo!
Why did he not rez?
Okay.
This Mirage is terrible.
This guy has 300 damage?
Bro, I'm lagging in my...
I'm getting more damage.
Is he crafting us?
Bro is not crafting us here.
He is crafting us.
Bro is not crafting us here and reviving us here.
Nooooo!
Why is he ulting?
Bro, is he...
Is he actually rezzing us here?
Bro, are you... I mean, he can do invisible.
Yeah, but why did he...
Why did he do that?
Nooooo way!
We're so fucked.
Oh no way!
We're so dead.
I hope they shoot you first.
No way!
Oh no, we're so fucked.
I love this.
They're gonna... They're flying!
They're flying!
Oh no!
Where are they flying?
I don't know.
Oh shit.
On us.
They're on us, aren't they?
Are they on us?
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
We can get our stuff!
They flew to him!
Wait, he's dead!
Let's get our stuff!
Alright.
Everything worked out.
Yeah, it all... Yeah, everything worked out for us.
We'll... We'll give it back to you, man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll...
We'll be back.
Don't worry.
Double it and give it to the next person.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
We'll be there.
Oh, he's there in front of us.
Tengen, they're in front of us.
They literally flew to us.
What did you do?!
That's crazy.
One's cracked.
One's cracked fully low.
Like, that's two shots directed.
You're good.
No, I'm not.
I don't feel good.
I don't feel good!
You're good.
I don't think we did it.
Yeah, we can just queue up.
Yeah, we can queue again.
Thank you, Apex.
Yeah, thank you.
So we don't have to...
Bro, they actually fucking blocked...
What the fuck?
What's wrong with them?
Freaks.
They're actual freaks.
Okay, to be fair, we had a terrible third.
Like, to be fair, our third was...
Maybe we needed a fourth.
Maybe we need a fourth player to make up for this mirage.
We do.
Oh, yeah, so...
Wait, so...
X to find, you just think it's way too slow?
Um...
I guess?
But, I mean, I'll give it a shot, right?
Yeah.
I'm down.
I was planning to download it.
Bro, let's fucking play it.
Let's do it next week.
For real?
Yeah, fucking let's do it!
Let's do it next week!
For real?
Yeah, we'll play on your servers.
Cause your internet's dog shit.
No shit.
Like, literally, last week, like, some cable on the ocean was like, broke down into like something, I guess.
Wait, what?
Yeah, so we got redirected to another whole server.
So we could not connect to Singapore.
What?
So there's a whole lot of latency for a couple of while.
Wait, was that for like Indonesia?
Only?
Uh...
I guess?
It happened for like five, four days.
Oh my god!
How do you live like that?
I can't...
I don't know, it's been decades.
I'm just like thinking like...
We had worse.
Oh my god!
Wait, so a shark bit the cable?
Probably.
What the fuck?
It happens.
We never knew what really happened.
That's crazy.
I just suddenly got emailed like, oh, something's wrong under the water.
What the fuck?
I'm sorry.
Here's a compensation.
Oh my god, and the server crashed.
Oh wait!
It's okay guys.
I thought that was my internet.
That was so funny.
That was my internet.
Oh no, the shark bit another cable.
Like, there's no way.
That was like the timing of that too.
I was like, there's no way.
A shark literally...
bit another cable.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh no.
That's not the gun I wanted.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, I might need help.
Oh wait.
No, he's low!
He's flashed!
What the fuck?
What?
Calm down.
Sorry, I was watching the horizon.
The horizon was pretty embarrassing.
What?
You were yelling at me and you were spectating at the wrong person?
Look, no, no, no.
I was still knocked, okay?
Look, I didn't realize you were not the horizon.
But you're playing...
Wait, what's her name again?
Alter?
What do you think about Alter?
It's fun.
Like, I can make portals randomly and people just get thrown off.
I feel like Alter...
I made a portal out of nowhere and they just go through it.
I feel like Alter, you need to have a good team to play with her.
Cause she's so...
Oh, she's...
This guy has bad connection.
Wait, what the fuck?
Who is that guy?
And got him?
He did?
I need a heal?
Oh!
I'm okay.
Can I swap?
Is there a swap?
One's knocked.
One left behind that stone.
Oh, there he is.
He got this, right?
Bro, I swear to fucking god.
I swear to fucking...
Okay, I have a gold red shield.
Yeah, that's why.
I literally just got it.
You don't even know.
Yeah, I know.
Don't worry about it.
I'm your teammate.
Sure.
There's a phoenix kit here.
Oh, you already have one.
Okay.
I'm using one right now.
Yay!
Where's that dude with the...
Freaking...
Whatever, hop up thing.
Alright, what's your...
Where are you planning on streaming now that you're back?
I gots to debut first.
At least.
You could be a PNG.
Forever?
No thanks.
Yeah, but you could be a PNG until you debut.
Because you don't know when you're debuting yet.
Maybe tomorrow.
Wait, actually?
Wait, what?
So, like, legit, it's just a stinger.
It's just a stinger.
Yeah, I am.
But you don't know when that's gonna be.
You know, like, I bet, like, you can just debut without the stinger and then you just, like, it just shows up one day.
Yeah, I could do that.
Because the intro and the outro is done.
Yeah, it's just the stinger, yeah?
Yeah.
I know what it looks like, chat.
I know what it looks like.
No you don't.
Yes I do.
Guys, it has white hair.
No.
I shouldn't make you bet.
Like, you don't deserve that.
What if I change my hair color?
You would change the hair color just to spite me?
Just to fuck with me?
Yeah, I'm against you.
That's so fucked up, man.
That's so fucked up.
Yeah, hell.
Yeah, he's like an old...
Oh yeah, you're...
I shouldn't reveal your lore yet.
Because it's a secret.
I have a lore?
It's crazy.
Yes you did.
You fucking told me the lore.
I didn't.
Yes you did.
Nuh uh.
I can say it right now and...
Hell.
I can say it right now.
Nuh uh.
What lore?
Are you gonna bait me?
What are you talking about?
Yeah, bro.
Don't fucking...
Don't bait me because now I really want to say it.
Yeah, yeah.
Hell.
Anyway, he's gonna be like...
I don't know if you guys know, but he's really old.
And um...
Man, I'm dead.
He's like an old grandpa.
And like in his lore...
He has like white hair.
It's always about the white hair.
It's the only thing he can say that won't actually leak anywhere.
That's honestly true.
Oh my god.
That's all you guys need to know.
People didn't know...
That I'm an old guy.
That's the thing, man.
Yeah, so old.
You're not supposed to know you're old?
Then change your hair color.
I'm 12.
Seconds away from dying.
Oh my god.
To be fair, when are you like...
Not dying though.
To be fair.
I'm a sleeve.
Good question.
I feel like after... maybe you won't even get a stream tomorrow.
Because you're gonna fucking...
Jesus Christ.
You're hoping me to die?
What?
No!
I'm just talking about the odds.
The odds of that happening, you know?
The odds of me dying...
Because of natural causes is way smaller...
It's like way...
Than getting into an accident.
Okay, I'm just saying.
Putting it out there.
I'm just saying.
Just don't go outside.
Yeah, just like... imagine.
There's like a random shark just jumping at me.
Just don't go outside, Tenjin.
Then you'll be fine.
But I like touching the grass.
No you don't.
What do you mean?
You assume I just stay at home?
If you had a choice, You would 100% just stay at home.
What do you mean?
Honestly, you're right.
I'm just saying.
There's no fucking way.
You hate going out.
Honestly, you're right.
I can't refute that.
Bro, okay, I was gonna say.
Even though I know you for like a couple of days.
A couple of days.
Just a couple of days.
I know that you do not like to go outside.
From those experiences from a couple of days.
Guys, just you know.
She's saying I'm a virgin, Chet.
Yeah, that too.
I mean, it's true.
That's crazy.
He's a fucking wizard.
She called me a fucking virgin.
That's crazy.
No, no.
It's called a wizard.
You're like a level 100 wizard right now.
You don't want to break that streak.
She's calling me old now.
I've been calling you old since the stream started.
My title is literally grandpa.
It's literally carrying this old grandpa.
Where are we going?
I don't know.
I see nothing.
I don't want to be outside of the zone.
That's stupid.
That's true.
Is she wrong?
Is she?
Damn.
Even the chats are against me now.
Look what you did.
Yay!
I did my job.
Influencer.
Yeah, I'm an influencer, guys.
Double it and give it to the next one.
I'm an influencer.
Wait, were you watching that part in Rust?
Is that why?
The part where I was like, hello, I'm an influencer.
I think I was.
I was smoking outside.
I was like, why were you...
You were smoking outside just watching me fuck around in Rust.
Okay, again, I miscalculated the stream time and my sleep time.
Yeah.
It's time to stream.
I woke up.
It's 2AM.
What happened?
What am I gonna do?
What the fuck?
This guy just...
Yeah, yeah, he had white armor.
By the way, there's another team up the hill.
I was not...
I thought you don't like being outside the zone.
Yeah, but like we can gatekeep them.
Or I could put a nexus.
Oh, true, true, true.
You're so smart.
I forgot about that.
I don't know if they're still there, but I saw them chilling up there.
Yeah, my MrBeast arc.
Just double it.
Double it and give it to the next one.
Oh, shit.
The ring is even like...
You sure about this?
I mean, it's round two.
I think there are two that are left.
They're not!
You big liar.
Oh my god!
I'm not a liar!
I just didn't know!
You big lie man.
Oh my god.
I mean, you killed all of them.
Fuck you going to the nexus.
I wiped the whole tour.
Yeah, I'm going to the nexus.
Bye.
I gotta loot all this stuff first though.
I think there's another team near us.
Yeah, there should be at least.
Alright, I'm going back.
This shit hurts, yo.
Yeah, it's round two though.
It's not that bad.
I wanna see another team though near us.
Yay!
Oh, ow, ow, ow.
I don't have a medkit?
I'm fucked.
You don't have syringes?
I have syringes, but not medkits.
Oh, you almost timed that wrong.
Yeah.
I predicted it wrong.
Oh, hey look.
There should be meds here.
I'm going to grab some syringes.
Oh, okay.
I found three fucking bats instead.
If you want.
I need medkits and syringes.
Yeah, I...
This is my last one.
I have one syringe here.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's do this.
I know there was one behind the tower.
I know there was one behind us, but I'm lazy.
I'm too lazy to take that.
I'm too lazy to walk behind us.
I'm going to go to zone.
That's crazy.
Oh, I'm going to go to zone.
Wait.
Behind us?
Up top?
Oh shit.
Why am I being shot at?
Behind us.
Just don't let them break our armor.
Then we'll have a...
Significant advantage.
Yeah.
Because we just don't have heals.
That's really it.
As long as they don't break our armor, we're fine.
Where are they shooting us from?
From that room.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
What?
What am I looking at?
Where's the other team then?
Okay, they're behind a shield.
I ain't fighting that.
Yeah, I'm not fighting that.
That's stupid.
They're behind a shield.
I'm not doing that.
I broke their shield.
They're shooting me without it now because I broke...
Wait, someone died to ring.
Wait, what?
The other team is dying to ring.
What the fuck?
Yeah, because they're the ones two hours left.
Yeah, but who's the ring people?
Don't ask me.
What the fuck?
What are we ever gonna do?
We just wait.
This is...
They have to come to us.
Yeah, see they're over here, left side.
I told you.
Oh, that is super low.
They just have to come to us.
Perfect made.
No?
Nevermind.
Flesh?
No, it...
That's not reachable?
I'm just gonna push up a little.
Oh, one is up here, by the way.
Wait, this is two different teams.
I just realized.
One is above us and the other one is to our left.
Uh...
Oh shit, that's me.
Yeah.
Why are they...
So one is like up here.
There's so much stuff.
It's fine, we'll be fine, right?
We'll be fine, right?
Are we?
I believe in us.
Oh shit!
Okay.
That guy was stupid.
Help me over here.
With this guy.
I can't climb.
There's a reason why.
Alright, I'm gonna take his loot then.
Wait, what?
Who's this guy?
He's just... he's just you.
Alright.
Where did he come from?
Okay, I'm just gonna heal.
You're fine, right?
I'm fine.
Okay, I'm gonna take his... I'm gonna loot then.
Are you still fine?
Oh my god, he went down.
Wait, where's the last guy then?
Don't know.
You're alive?
I wouldn't even know.
I don't know where he is.
I swear I saw some guy here.
Where the fuck did he go?
Okay.
What the fuck?
Where did he go?
Oh.
Wait.
Oh he's behind.
That's the whole team!
That's the whole team.
Please!
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Don't let them push.
Where did this team come from?
OH.
I'M DEAD!
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead!
Peek me!
I'm not dead I'm not dead.
Knocked one.
I'm not dead.
I'm dead.
I'm gonna go for this guy.
There's one.
Behind you, behind you.
I know I need to...
Okay, I got one.
I'm gonna have to flourish this guy.
I'm gonna thirst him.
He's right here.
I'm gonna thirst him though.
Okay, I'm getting over.
Don't die!
I'm here.
Okay, he thirsted him too.
There's no way he wins this 1v2.
Yeah, he's won.
Nice.
See?
Aw.
He said sorry.
Hell yeah.
You better be...
Whatdo you, what'd he say?
He said sorry.
Oh my God.
Oh.
My.
God.
Wow.
My God, he was stream sniping us!
Tenshin.
Oh my God!
This guy!
SEEDOON!
You're gonna stream Sniperz?
You should have had more than 1k damage.
Not gonna lie.
This is a little embarrassing.
That's true.
You don't know if he's a dragoon.
He could be like whatever the fuck Tengen's chat is.
What do you call your chat?
Bro...
I have yet to reveal that just yet.
Reveal?
Let's do it now.
No.
Why not?
It would be like an exclusive.
Hell no.
Anjing.
Is it Anjing?
What does that mean?
Tengen, I've never heard that before.
What does that really mean?
Yeah, I've never heard that.
It means a dog or a bitch.
Oh yeah, how do you say that fully?
How do you say that fully?
Tengen?
Yeah.
Anjing.
Anjing what?
Isn't there more to that?
I'm pretty sure that was...
Really?
There's no need to...
Is there not?
Probably not.
Chat, is that...
Is that true?
There are people who look at your chat.
Your chat would tell the truth.
Yeah.
Alright.
No.
Nah.
Yeah?
Anjing what?
My chat's a gaslighter.
Anjing.
An...
Nah.
Wait, do you call your chat Anjing now?
Sometimes, yeah.
Oh my god, you call your chat dogs?
Yeah.
Sometimes.
Maybe they like it.
They have to behave like a puppy.
Yeah, they do.
Maybe they like it.
I'm sure they do.
Tenjin's Anjing's.
Guys, I can't get in trouble because it's Tenjin's fault.
What?
It's not my fault.
I'm just trying to learn.
Nah, it was never my fault.
My behavior is mostly because of my friends.
Me too.
So I blame my friends.
Yeah, I blame...
blame my friends too.
Thank God we just met each other.
Yeah, thank God we just met.
So we're not friends.
We...
We're just acquaintances guys.
Well...
Akquaintance.
Yeah.
I'm just saying.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We were just randos.
Yeah, we were just randos and we just want to win some Apex games, you know.
We like Apex.
Yeah, we're just like damn, you're so good at Apex.
Like you wanna like fucking do a collab, so we can boost our win rates.
Nemesis's.
Oh, I got the wrong person with that.
Oops.
Hope you don't die.
Heading over?
Wait, there's a guy right here in front of me.
Yeah, someone's on you.
Were you champions?
What the fuck?
Was I?
Oh my god!
I couldn't even look!
I'm so fucked.
Alright.
Yeah, that guy instantly killed me.
It was actually crazy.
I literally looked up and got beaten.
Wait.
Oh my god, maybe he'll rez me too.
I got scammed?
I'm safe though.
I'm really safe.
I'm really safe, Tangent.
Okay, you're dead.
I'm still very safe.
Wait, did he thirst again?
There's a whole different team.
Oh, rez.
I'm safe for rez.
No lie.
Do you think he'll rez me?
Oh, he got peacekeep.
Okay, he's fucking dead.
Boom!
Wait, wait, he won that.
Oh, he's dead.
There's two shotguns in that team.
There's no way.
He should have rez'd.
We would have fucking helped him.
We would have, yes.
Yeah!
Wait, I have an idea.
You have zero damage.
Okay, I literally looked up and died.
That's not fair.
I literally looked up and died.
Welcome to my servers.
No, in NA, we would have fucking died so fast.
That's where all the ruler players live.
You know that.
You played NA servers.
No, I have not.
Yes, you have.
I have not.
What are you talking about?
Oh, true, true, true.
Sorry, I was thinking about somebody else.
We met in... I think we met in Tokyo.
Like, we met like the day before your final... the finals tournament.
And that's why I was lurking in his chat.
If you guys want a timeline of everything.
You're stretching it.
Yeah, that's our timeline.
That's the canon event.
Right.
Yeah, yeah, and we met on like Tokyo servers, right?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, yeah, so it was on Tokyo servers that we bumped into each other.
And then like...
Coincidentally, it was off stream.
Yeah, it was off stream.
I was like, real Doki?
Yeah, and then...
No way.
Oh my god, yeah.
And he's like a huge fan of me, by the way.
So, he's actually a Dragoon.
He's been like a...
Like a...
He's been a Dragoon member for like...
How many months now?
Five months, right?
Why don't you prove it in chat right now?
In my chat and type, show your membership badge.
And show that it's real.
Hey, aren't you a member?
Mm-hmm.
Was.
Was what happened?
We became friends.
Oh, I thought we were acquaintances.
Oh yeah, we just became friends like right now.
So, he un-membered.
I can be a fan and a friend at the same time.
Yeah, so why aren't you membering?
I need to pay my electricity bills.
Okay, true, true.
All right, don't worry.
You can never die now.
You think my water bills are like...
Crazy.
That's crazy.
Damn, you got me there.
Yeah, he had to cancel his membership to me because he had to pay his bills.
Yeah.
It's okay guys.
So like guys, that means like...
Guys, you have to superchat to Tenjin so that he can afford to member.
Guys, I need him to member to me so...
Why do you want me to member you?
I have your chat open.
Someone literally gave you a superchat.
It's time.
Why you have my chat open?
That's so... what?
Hey...
That's crazy.
Because you said you couldn't afford it.
You said you couldn't afford it.
So now you should...
You should be able to afford it now, right?
Unless you were lying to me.
I would never lie to you.
Alright, member me right now.
I'm in Apex.
Do you expect me to member you?
Oh, don't worry.
At the end of the stream, we're gonna watch you member me, right?
What?
What is that statement, man?
Join Tomato Farm.
What?
Nah...
People are pressuring me to do this now, huh?
Your pressure is okay sometimes.
Sometimes?
Oh, you're right.
All the time.
You're right.
There's like a huge fight going on in front of me, by the way.
Don't worry.
I'm lifelike.
If you go there and die, and then I rez you just like Mercy.
Die, I have rez.
What the fuck is going on?
What are you doing?
You have a healer drone.
You deserve it.
I... yeah.
You deserve this.
Oh, in front of me?
In front of me?
Okay, okay.
Knocked one.
Second person is here.
What is he doing here?
Got the second one.
Engine, die!
I have rez!
Die, I have rez!
Just like Overwatch.
What are you just like Overwatch at?
I'm more like Mercy.
I've never played Overwatch.
What the fuck do you do?
What are you talking about?
How do you know that?
Die, I have rez.
Just like Marble Rivals.
And you know you can't say you don't have it.
You don't.
Okay, okay.
You can't lie.
I don't know why you can't lie.
Because I gave him a fucking code for Marble Rivals.
Yes, I'm calling you out.
I gave this man a fucking code for Marble Rivals.
So you can't lie about it.
What?
You sold your soul to me now.
Bro!
Yeah?
Yeah, yeah.
This is your fault.
No, I know you said you want a code for Marble Rivals.
No, this is your fault.
Someone sent a red.
Oh, someone sent a red.
You know what to do.
This is your fault.
How is that my fault?
I'm doing this.
What the fuck?
You're a scam.
I can't believe it.
This guy scammed me.
No, no, no.
Hail.
Where's membership?
I haven't even debuted yet.
That's... man.
Damn.
What?
Where are we going?
I don't know.
I'm fucking Lifeline.
Your IGF.
I'm Lifeline.
Okay, we're following the Bangalore.
Okay, you so nasty.
Why?
That's the guy's name.
What do you mean why?
That's literally the guy's name.
Oh, that's the guy's name?
I'm streamer mode.
Oh, you're streamer mode.
Why are you streamer mode?
Why?
Are you scared of dying?
No.
What are you doing?
Get your shit off streamer mode.
What are you scared of?
What are you laughing about?
No, no, no.
Don't worry about it.
What are you doing?
I'm fucking pulling up your stream right now.
Nothing.
There's nothing.
What are you doing?
Nothing.
No, I didn't do anything.
Don't worry about it.
They don't really like it.
Nothing.
I didn't do anything.
Trust me.
You did something.
You fucking did something.
I didn't do anything.
Why you don't trust me?
We literally just met.
You don't trust me.
I do trust you to the point where I cannot trust you.
Because I trust you to not trust.
That's how hard it is.
For real.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Let's see.
Oh wait.
I have a...
I have a package.
Where the fuck are people though?
Oh.
Oh I see them.
I see them.
Cracked one.
You just have to ask.
They're like all the way over to the other side.
What do we have here?
Someone's flying.
Just bats.
Wait.
Is there?
Oh wait.
They are.
That's the team I like cracked I think.
Yeah they are.
Wait.
Where?
I don't see them.
Where did they fly?
Oh I see them.
I see them.
Do we have...
Do I have ammo?
I need ammo.
What kind of ammo do you need?
Blue armor?
Red?
I'm doing season 3 meta.
Wait.
PK.
Oh you're doing PK wingman.
I fucking knew it.
Like the moment he said season 3.
I fucking knew it was PK.
I don't even remember the dictionary.
Bro season 3 is...
Season 3 and 4 were my friend out like...
Like friend years.
A fucking course I remember is season 3 fucking meta.
Oh my god.
That shit is ingrained in my mind.
You were...
Over here.
And to my right as well.
There's like... I don't know if it's the same team.
Shit.
You should craft some... You can craft some ammo.
I thought I cracked something already dude.
Probably.
I mean they're playing Gibby.
And Octane.
Why are they playing Gibby?
I never see Gibby anymore.
I swear to god.
Cause isn't it...
What do I move?
What are they doing?
Do you see that Gibby not moving?
Is that Gibby just chilling there behind the rock?
Oh it's cause there's a new team.
Yeah this Gibby is so...
Oh my god.
This Gibby is so fucked.
Um...
Like a Nexus.
I'm gonna... Yeah get that Nexus in.
Uhhh...
Okay let's go.
You go first.
Wait you have a user portal.
Wait can I... Does it even go through that?
Oh here I can do that.
Over there.
Oh okay yeah.
Yeah it's...
Where's like his teammates though?
Why is he taking the Nexus?
What?
Did he fuck up?
Did he use up the Nexus?
Oh he's stupid.
He's special.
It's Singapore service.
Okay.
I'm in front of this.
Alright I literally have a sniper.
So I'm counting on you.
Wait he is.
Yeah he is.
Dude who's on your right?
What the fuck?
I thought you were supposed to help me.
He ran away.
Why is he scared?
Cause...
You're dope.
We should go for the guy to our left.
That one?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't see him but yeah.
Oh my god.
Cracked like two of them.
He's so low.
You got this.
I believe in you.
Literally one...
Oh it's okay.
It's okay.
Watch this.
That's why I'm lifelined.
Yo you even got like a...
Field drone.
Someone's behind you.
You're fine.
Oh!
Yeah yeah exactly.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
Where are you?
Where did you die?
You need to...
No.
I told you.
You're so fine.
Huh?
Oh my god.
I told you.
Guys we have to go.
Go.
Ow.
I'm leaving by the way.
The zone is coming.
Hey but I have a package.
I'm so healthy.
I know there's like one more team.
Somewhere here.
Do you have your Q?
Uh no I used it.
But I do have...
A knockdown shield.
Would I need that?
Uh we need a go go.
I'm gonna take the redeploy.
I have a...
Thingy.
Whatever.
Oh a redeploy?
The fly.
Yeah.
Yeah I'm gonna take that then.
You guys can take yours.
I'll take this in front of me.
Let's go bang!
Come on!
It would be so funny if I died from getting shot from this.
It would be so funny.
It would be so fucking funny.
Where are we going?
Straight?
Let's head to zone.
We're literally so far from zone.
Yep.
I'm gonna head to this actually.
And then fly over it.
Do another jump down?
Yeah.
I think we're fine.
We're so safe.
Like what are you gonna do?
Kill us?
Someone's resing.
Where?
Oh.
Okay.
Then we'll go here.
Down here.
That's good.
Yeah.
Then we'll shoot them and kill them.
Oh I see them.
They're too far left.
Yeah.
He's literally right there.
Okay.
Yeah there's nobody here.
There's nobody here.
I'm gonna go up.
Didn't they just craft a mobile res beacon I'm pretty sure.
You can craft a mobile res beacon.
I think you can right?
There's a lot of dead bodies in there.
That must be where they died.
Oh I see them.
Oh.
Full team.
Okay.
Yeah I'm gonna chill.
I'm chilling.
Whoa!
Back away!
I'm using my heal drone.
Someone step on that please.
Come on.
Where the fuck are you doomed?
It's so funny.
If someone steps in there.
They are not stepping.
You know damn well they are not stepping on it.
Oh they will.
Eventually they will.
They are not stepping on it.
Tension.
Eventually they will.
Trust me.
Wait they have to leave though.
Yeah they do.
Cause they're not in zone.
Alright I'm leaving.
We're not in zone.
Yeah I was gonna say.
Tension they didn't step on it.
I thought you said they would.
Nobody is that blind.
Don't worry about it.
I am.
Let me see if I can climb up this.
Nice.
Okay.
What?
Okay I fucked up.
I fucked up.
They might rush now.
What did you do?
I fucked up.
I thought they weren't gonna turn around.
What did you do?
I nearly walked them.
Guys I really need a rez.
They're gonna rush with this.
Guys.
Tension.
You have the mobile.
You have the mobile rez.
You have the gold rez right?
Oh they're here.
They're here.
I'm gonna take your.
Okay that nexus is.
You'll be fine.
Taking your nexus.
You got me right?
No no no no.
Bro what the fuck is this nexus?
You got me right?
Take the nexus.
Take the fucking nexus.
Oh.
You got me right?
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's do this.
There's a craft.
Yeah I do.
Right there.
And then you craft in the big mod.
Yeah I do.
You got this.
Yeah.
This is awkward.
Wait they're getting shot at.
Yeah I told you just craft.
You know and leave.
Where?
Craft.
Dude on your right.
Hello?
What the fuck?
Dude.
What?
What is wrong?
Oh that's right you fucking.
That's right you're.
They're dead.
This is round three.
You killed us.
Bro.
I want you to watch them die.
No they died by default.
We won by default.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking.
You didn't see that.
Oh that's a cool ass name.
I can't believe it.
We could have saw this.
We won by default.
Don't worry about it.
Honestly true true true.
They died.
That means we won automatically.
Yeah we won.
Easy.
You're right.
It was easily a GG's anyway.
That's crazy.
I can't believe they threw.
They just didn't go to zone.
They could have.
Yeah.
That's all they had to do.
Yeah we won chat.
Yeah we won.
Don't worry about it.
We won the mental game.
Shit.
The mental game.
Yeah we won the mental warfare.
Mentally I am not here.
True.
Mentally I'm in Tarkov.
Bro you're still playing as GAM.
No.
I haven't touched it in like.
See you fucking bought that 50% shit.
And then you're fucking playing.
Oh shit.
I'm letting you.
I'm a wingy.
Alright.
I have a flat line.
Don't die.
That's all I can say.
Just don't die.
Oh is that guy gonna leave?
I might be dead though.
Our guy left.
What the fuck?
Hey I'm missing all my shi- No!
I flashed.
Oh no.
I got flashed.
Don't worry I shield you.
I got you.
What are you doing bro?
Oh my god bro.
Wait.
Don't die like this.
Ohhhh.
Okay that was sick.
There's no team.
Okay.
I expected that from far away.
That was cool.
I expected that from far far away.
You died to cream de la pussy.
I broke his knees.
Oh my god.
That was cool though.
I expected that so much.
That was that back and forth.
There's a second team.
There is.
We landed with like four teams.
Oh my god.
I mean you clutched it.
You clutched it and then you died.
Yeah well that's a win in my book.
Oh shit.
Okay he must have a shotgun ball.
There's no way.
That swap was so fucking fast.
Did you see that?
That's...
That was such a fucking fast swap.
Man.
I have been streaming Apex for three days straight.
Have I?
Were you actually streaming Apex?
Really?
I thought you played finals.
Yeah after finals there's Apex and then Apex and then a break.
And then Apex at night and then Apex.
And then now you Apex.
Yay.
I mean it shows.
It shows that you're warmed up.
Well...
Probably.
It's mostly stupidity.
Because it's just the boys.
Oh because you guys are playing rank right?
Yeah we were.
Yeah that's why you're gold.
Because someone challenged us.
Well someone challenged my teammate.
That if we reach masters someone's gonna buy him like a scuf controller or something like that.
I don't know.
But yeah.
What the fuck?
Why does he want a controller?
Because he's a controller player.
I don't know.
Oh wait no tell him to get him a battle beaver.
What's that?
That's like the controller that everybody uses.
Like all the pros uses.
For real?
Yeah.
I know because I bought one and I never used it.
That's...
Yeah.
I know we just met but I could tell you'd do that.
You knew that.
Wait so like he needs to be masters to get that?
Yeah.
But that's so fucking easy.
I know right?
Yeah.
Wait what rank is he now?
Gold 1 I guess.
Yeah but how long...
How many days left till rank is over?
I'm not sure actually.
I'm pretty sure it's not that...
Like there's still a long time right?
Rank just started.
Guys how many more days till rank is over?
Whoa whoa whoa I got freaked out.
I'm here I'm coming over.
JK I'm looting.
I'm looting right now.
You guys are fine right?
He has 26 days bro that's so easy.
Yeah there's a lot.
Yeah you can literally get that in like...
Like 2 weeks.
We got this.
Like literally 2 weeks you can get masters.
That's so fucking easy.
No no no no no.
Wait what?
You guys need HP?
I can't get on the goddamn train.
What the fuck are you doing?
For some reason.
Okay there's a team on the other side.
Yeah that's why I wanted to go there.
I don't see them though.
But I know they landed there.
Where are they?
Where the fuck are they?
They're all over there.
Pigeon look.
Look with your eyes.
Tell me where they are.
Oh true you're Asian.
So am I.
We are all.
Alright don't worry I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
I wanna go through that too.
Wait where are they?
What the fuck?
I didn't finish you on this guy.
Accidentally.
Where are you?
Over there below.
Flesh?
JK?
What?
I'm being shot by another squad.
Behind us?
Okay.
There's a wingman here.
You want it?
Hold on.
I'll take it.
Oh that's insane.
You needed the...
I don't think they're pushing.
There's no way they're pushing.
They're too scared.
I don't think I'll switch the loom in just a second.
Wait I don't see them?
I don't see them.
Yeah let's just head over.
Yeah.
Alright.
Yeah of course.
Are you scared?
No.
Yeah don't be a little bitch.
When did you become a little bitch?
Yeah.
Yeah you're not a little... Tell the world you're not a little bitch.
Okay he's a little bitch.
No I'm too tired.
I've been awake since 2 man.
What the fuck?
You're like literally...
He's super low.
Oh yeah he's dead.
Nice he's dead too.
Wait where did his teammate go?
Did he run?
You got this.
I'm thirsting.
I'm watching you.
Yeah see?
You almost fucking died.
Here's a kill drone.
That's a little embarrassing.
Yeah hey I punched him like a man.
I showed myself I am no bitch.
Yeah didn't you miss?
No I didn't.
Oh you didn't?
Oh I thought you missed.
That's why you punched him.
Well I ran out of ammo.
I'm gonna go get some more ammo.
Talk to grandpa that way.
Grandpa is like a hardened war veteran.
He can take it.
He's used to it.
Yes yes.
The worst was my wife.
My ex-wife.
She uh...
I thought you were a level 100 wizard.
She divorced me as soon as the same day as we got married.
Oh cause you save it for marriage.
Is that what you're trying to plot?
Oh hey golden triple take.
Waaaaaah it's gone.
Hey hey hey stop shooting me.
Stop shooting me.
I'm heading over.
Wait they're white armor.
For real?
Yeah.
Why are you saying that?
I'm scared.
They're literally...
Why?
They're white armor.
That's some break.
Punch him.
Yeah.
Babies.
They're actual babies.
Is he just by himself or what?
I don't fucking know.
I'm fucking stealing his shit.
What?
No he was...
There was a bloodhound.
I think the bloodhound ran.
Why?
I don't know.
They're white armor.
What do you think why?
They shot me and they see purple.
Oh there they are.
Oh my god.
Wait this guy is actually a baby.
He's right here.
He's flesh.
You can literally kill him.
Well this guy is an actual child.
Did you kill him?
So fucked up.
You actually killed a child.
In game.
My specialty.
Wait your specialty?
Wait how many children?
Wait.
More than my fingers.
Alright.
Oh man.
Seven more teams.
Alright what are your plans for streams?
When you debut?
Benjen.
What plan are you doing?
I honestly.
I'm not sure.
I have no clue.
I'm only here to fuck around and find out.
But he has one to see him stream.
Guys.
They want to see me naked.
Wait is that true?
Yeah.
Guys you can't see him naked.
You gotta marry him first.
What?
That's why.
That's one big super chat.
Chat you can't see him naked guys.
Wait will you marry all of your chat then?
What?
If they want to see you naked.
Huh?
They want to see him naked.
But I'm shy.
Well.
That's why you got divorced.
Oh my god.
Oh man.
I got divorced one day.
Poor guy.
Damn.
It's okay man.
It's okay bro.
Shut up.
I don't want to hear that from you.
Bro it's okay bro.
Everything will be okay bro.
I ain't hearing that.
One day it's okay.
Being level 100 is okay.
I'm a champion and one wizard.
It's also cool.
Oh there's enemies in front of me too.
Don't care about that guy.
Yeah don't care about him.
But our teammate is a youtuber.
Don't care.
Don't care about him.
We can craft him.
He's a youtuber.
He's from youtube.
It's fine.
We don't care.
We're gonna teach him a lesson.
I can...
There was a res in front of me.
Should I just make him a nexus?
Should I make him a nexus?
No what the fuck.
He's gotta learn.
He'll never learn.
We just rotated the whole line.
Yeah but we saw a res.
It's okay.
We saw a res so like it was worth it.
And also we're going to zone.
We're just trying to find people.
Okay.
Alright I'm climbing up.
Stop bullying small content creators.
Attention.
I'm a small content creator.
No I'm not gonna say that.
Of course I know.
Yeah.
I'm sure you know that.
But like I'm here to give you courage.
I'm not bullying you right?
I'm inspiring you.
I'm inspiring you right now.
Oh my god.
What is this laugh?
Are you okay?
No I'm not.
I'm not okay.
Bro I had like the most insane lag ever.
That was actually crazy.
That lag was insane.
Where did it go?
Did it stop peaking?
Wait where?
I'm gonna take my package here.
Oh my god.
That lag was actually crazy.
I can't.
I can't climb it.
Oh my god.
Poor guys.
Poor guys like what the fuck is going on?
This guy lagged.
Oh my god.
We have 500 ping.
That's actually crazy.
Wait.
What I do is actually insane.
Okay.
I did something to that poor lifeline.
And like.
I feel bad.
What I did to him.
Oh my god.
I hit these but like it doesn't register.
I'm gonna go to the right.
Our guard is pushing.
Oh he's fucking crazy then.
You're crazy.
I mean there's two teams.
Yeah still.
I'm gonna heal.
He's on the roof.
What someone's on the roof?
Don't worry my shots are gonna hit like three seconds later.
Someone lagged.
That no ray.
How am I at 500 ping?
This is the worst gun to have.
To be lagging with.
Wait there's people behind us.
I'm heading over here.
I'm gonna head to my guy.
Okay I stopped lagging there at least.
I'm gonna fucking.
You think I won't?
I have so much ammo.
No please.
Please Dokie.
Don't do this to me.
No.
It'll be fine right?
Yeah see I knew it.
Woah.
We gotta go to zone though.
I'm heading over to zone.
Sure.
Right below.
Oh in front of us.
They're so far though.
They are.
What do we do?
I broke their thing so now they're scared.
We're gonna head to zone.
Someone's resing?
Okay I'm gonna head to the far right.
I'm gonna head to the tunnels.
Yeah they're just gonna camp us out.
Let's head to the tunnels.
It's not worth it.
The zone is closing anyway so.
Wait can we make it?
Wait I don't even know if we can make it to the tunnels.
Can we?
No we can't.
We actually can't.
We have to go like.
Do we have to?
I can't make that.
We have to go here.
I'm gonna go.
I'm just gonna go here then.
Are guys fighting?
Wait what?
I got this for you guys.
Wait we have your Q.
Yeah.
Yeah we have your Q to rotate.
Alright.
Climb up.
Is there a rez out here?
I'm not climbing up anymore.
I'm taking your portal.
Oh my god.
What?
They're blasting me.
What the fuck?
We can't camp that place.
Oh shit.
Jesus Christ.
What happened?
I have no clue.
What happened to you guys?
You died so fast.
I don't know.
That was bad.
All eyes were on me.
I literally went up the portal and everything was just gone.
I thought I was behind a pole and I was safe.
Yeah.
You were just gone.
Man.
You like literally got deleted so fast.
I'm not gonna lie.
That's Apex.
Oh.
It's okay.
It's alright.
We're gonna win this next one.
Cause we're better.
Oh hey.
We all did pretty well.
Hey that YouTuber guy did pretty good.
He was not dead weight.
He's alright.
Guys he was not dead weight.
He did it.
We got a random that actually did stuff.
Good for him.
Good on him.
Yay.
Why's the QN taking so long?
Apparently like I tweeted out that like I joined a cool religion.
Apparently, Klu In like I guess like Brazilian Is ass.
So I technically tweeted out I joined an ass religion today.
All my like Brazilian dragoons are really confused.
I never knew you were an ass person.
I was like wondering why there's so much Brazilian comments.
Oh shit it's KingShy.
Fuck!
Why did I play Alter?
Why did I go Alter?
Ah damn.
Yeah so apparently people were like...
Not judging.
Why are you saying ass?
So how'd you join the ass cult?
And like where do I sign up?
Did you just tear it open?
Did you tear it open or what?
Oh my god.
Whoops.
I mean it works still.
It works still.
Yeah it's Portuguese.
Yeah.
Apparently...
I don't even know how it's pronounced.
But like someone in my comments, the replies were like...
Ooh the Brazilian dragoons are coming.
And I got so confused.
I got so fucking confused.
I was like why?
It's silent and deadly religion.
And then I saw like...
I guess I saw Portuguese in my chat.
Like in my replies.
And I was like why is there so much Portuguese right now?
Going on in my replies.
Well now you know.
What's going on?
Bro I miss.
Oh wait there is...
Is there team on us?
Not really.
I'm not sure.
There shouldn't be.
Doki come to Brazil.
Then have a Brazilian convention invite me guys.
I'm down.
I wanna go to Brazil.
Like virtually.
You're going to Brazil.
Virtually.
Tell your local...
Not local.
Tell your conventions.
Your big...
Anime conventions to invite me.
To Brazil.
I'll come to Brazil.
Bro.
I don't know.
I don't know when.
You're the one that has the connections.
Hey man.
I link...
I try linking you up.
That's all I did.
Yo.
Okay look.
Look.
They just...
Okay to be fair.
That's on me.
Cause like I didn't reply back to...
Like the email.
No they didn't send me...
They didn't send me the new email.
I was waiting for the new email.
But it wasn't sent.
That's not fully on me.
Guys, guys, guys.
I need help.
Guys, guys, here.
I got distracted by Brazil.
I got distracted.
I blame Tengen.
You distracted me.
Yeah, that's why.
Now you're dead.
Now you're fucking dead.
We got the caustic in the team.
He got down.
Wait, wait, he can do this.
He's better.
He can.
He's so much better.
Someone's rezzing.
Yeah, it's the guy that our guy fucking...
Okay, he's not that better.
Never mind.
He's not that much better.
Look, maybe I'll be there at an Indonesian convention.
Maybe.
I just need, you know...
Tengen, tell them to email me.
On it.
Yeah.
I told you to tell them to email me.
And you just like replied back to the old email.
I was just like, yeah, but like it's the old email.
I need to...
It doesn't matter.
Yes, it does.
Because it's the old one.
All right, all right, all right.
Because that date was gone.
I'll try to set it up.
Okay.
Yeah.
You have a lot of fans in Indonesia.
Any Indo bros?
Indo bros, rise up.
Rise up.
There's a lot, bro.
I'm one of them.
Oh shit, you're right.
Yeah, the one that's...
Yeah, yeah, he's membered now, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he's my biggest fan.
Oh yeah, that's our story, right?
Yeah.
You were like the biggest Doki fan.
And then we bumped into each other.
I forgot our story almost.
We bumped into each other in Apex and he was fangirling me hard.
And he was like, oh my God, you're the real Doki Bird.
I've been following you for like...
Oh my God, is that Doki Bird?
Yeah, that's what he said in voice chat.
Yeah, that's what I said.
And then I blocked him.
Yeah, pretty much what happened.
Yeah, and then I blocked him because I was like, ugh.
Indeed.
I was like, oh my God.
I'm fucked.
So real.
They landed there?
Really?
I don't have a gun.
You don't have a gun.
I have one gun.
You know, like they made a thing where you loot a pill, they automatically give you a gun when you first land.
Shit.
Are they following us?
Oh fuck, no, I don't have a gun.
Hey, oh my God.
Oh, I'm going to rotate.
If you guys die, it's on you.
Oh, there's guns here.
I'm fine.
They are scared now.
They're scared.
I literally can barely see them, but they're scared.
I'm going to put this.
Yeah.
Okay.
What a wingman?
I found a turbocharger.
Okay.
I have...
Oh, wait, they're fighting.
The worst you could say was no.
No, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's worse...
Someone said like the worst thing she could say is no.
Nah.
There's more than that.
Oh yeah?
You have experience?
What?
I'd rather not talk about it.
Nah.
Oh no, trauma.
Yep.
Wanna go from behind?
We brought complex.
I'm from below.
I need help.
Complex?
I'm also fighting someone.
Oh crap.
Got one.
Oh god!
Wait,
wait, wait.
I need to swap.
No!
I gotta kill someone.
I'm fighting my demons.
Oh my god!
I'm fighting your demons right now!
He's up there.
He's up top.
He's up top still?
Why?
I don't fucking know.
Sick one.
Oh he hates you.
He's fucking BMing you.
Now you have to win.
So you can shit talk him after.
Oh no way.
You proved this point!
No way.
You proved it.
Yeah.
God damn.
Alt.
No way.
Damn.
You got called out.
Yeah.
You got fucking called out bro.
It doesn't matter.
Lots of trash in the sheet.
Oh man.
What do you think about Rival Rivalist so far?
I...
Very laggy.
Because there's no Asian server.
There's no Asian.
Yeah.
There's a thing.
I'm trying to enjoy the server.
It's just too laggy.
For the movements.
It's too much.
Oh my god.
Have you tried Spider-Man?
That fucking shit was crazy.
I main Spider-Man.
Why?
Why would you do that to yourself?
Hey the wall run.
The wall run is fun.
Yeah but it was like.
I tried to play Spider-Man.
I was like.
Like I wanted to throw up.
Nah.
You gotta combo it.
The motion was so bad.
Come on.
I thought you were good at FPS games.
What?
Oh yeah.
Yeah the fucking.
Spider-Man melee.
The FPS games.
Yeah.
Tangent.
It's first punching shooter.
So fucking true.
Exactly.
Where's our guy gonna take us?
Sir.
Where are you gonna take us?
Oh he's level 14.
Wait this guy's a baby.
This guy's acting like he's level 14.
Woah woah woah.
We're dropping in the shit.
Oh shit.
Hell no.
No I'm not dropping in the shit.
Wait is he actually trying to get to the shit?
He's trying to get to the shit.
At least he was.
He's fucking stupid.
And he didn't reach it.
Bro he's level 14.
Of course he's not.
Oh boy.
Is there anyone near us?
Probably not.
Yeah I'm gonna say.
That drop was terrible.
That drop was a level 14 drop.
Like oh my god.
That shit was terrible.
I'm gonna say I head to labs.
Oh I hear people fighting.
I'm heading over to the fight.
Where are you?
Where are you Tenjin?
What?
Movement weird.
Where the fuck are you?
I'm going man.
I'm going.
I might be a little slow.
Oh I know.
At least it's something.
Even if it's stupid.
Oh I need help.
Yes.
I'm right here.
Holy shit.
Yeah I definitely need help.
Oh.
He's one.
Oh that's you.
Okay.
I have to.
I have to do stuff.
Yeah see I knew you got this.
Wait where's his teammate?
Oh his teammate's coming.
Oh his teammate has no armor.
Okay.
That was embarrassing for him.
Uh huh.
His teammate has no more like armor at all.
Yay.
Wanna use that?
What?
I'm gonna use that.
Ultimix?
Why?
This is not rank.
Tengen?
Oh yeah it's not rank.
Who the fuck cares?
I have PTSD's.
I can tell.
We literally have like the ult shit right here too.
We literally have the charge tower.
I was like what the fuck?
I keep forgetting R9 is dog shit now.
It sucks.
Yeah same.
I keep fucking...
I need to like swap my gun.
My scroll wheel is double clicking.
What?
That is the most annoying part that I'm having.
Is your mouse broke?
Yeah I really wanna fix it but then I'm lazy.
What do you mean?
Just buy a mouse.
You and your stuff.
What do you mean?
If it's broken.
Man.
Hey man I can...
I can fix it.
Did you forget where I'm from?
A third world country.
Oh true.
Just go out and buy it so you don't have to worry about customs.
Yeah go through the jungle and...
Yeah go through the jungle and then...
There has to be mouse stores.
And miss money bags.
No he's talking about customs.
He's not talking about like...
Not being able to afford it.
He's talking about customs.
Cause like Indonesian customs is like terrible when it comes to shopping.
Yeah.
Like shipping stuff.
Yes.
Even though like...
You know you declare it.
Oh it's a gift.
And they're like no it's not.
Yeah so like...
And then you get like taxed or whatever right?
Yeah isn't there like...
I'm calling them out.
Legit.
What are they gonna do like send somebody over?
They're gonna charge me for something that I didn't order.
If Tenzin doesn't show up for his own debut tomorrow.
We know what happened.
Even if there's documents like declaring this is a gift.
Gift cannot be like you know.
You can't charge that shit.
And they're like nuh uh.
It's not a gift.
You got this.
Yeah so just go out and...
Just...
Can you go out and like...
Buy a mouse?
Mouse.
Can you just do that?
I don't even know what to buy now.
Just fucking get a G Pro Wireless.
Again?
I mean that's the classic.
I'm using G Pro Wireless.
Yeah but aren't you like... isn't your G Pro Wireless fucking up right now?
Only the scroll wheel.
I can change the switches.
Like I did with the other clicks.
You're just gonna change your bindings?
No, I soldered it.
Like I tear it apart, I soldered my shit.
Oh man, that's so much work.
I swapped it with a better switch.
Yeah but like it's so much easier to just...
Doesn't have that mushy click when I bought it on day one.
But it's so much easier to just, you know...
Wait, to our left?
There's people to my right.
Someone's dropping over there.
Yeah, it's a full team.
I think they saw me.
Wait, what the fuck?
There's another team here.
Right there.
Yeah, I think they saw you man.
I think they saw me too.
I think they saw you.
I think they saw me.
Dude, we're fucked!
I think they saw both of you.
Dude, we're fucked.
There's two teams.
There's two teams!
I think we're both fucked.
Bro, there's two teams.
I think we're both fucked, guys.
Uh-huh.
I don't think they saw me, right?
No!
Aye.
Yep.
They wouldn't see you.
How would they see you?
How would they know?
I don't know.
They don't know.
How would they know?
They wouldn't know.
Who the fuck shot me in the back?
They know.
I got away for so long.
Just go.
I got away for so long!
So they did know.
How did they know?
No, they're hacking.
So they did know.
They're hacking.
There's no way.
Yeah, for real.
Shit.
There's no way.
Somebody get those, like, IP ban.
Ah, hardware ban!
Somebody...
What?
What.
Did somebody just super chat for you to get a mouse?
Mmm, more-more or less.
Courtesy of the Dragoons.
Somebody was like, what the fuck.
That's craaaauen overly.
Mouse fun!
Go fucking get a better mouse!
Yeah, but like, this is...
I could fix this.
And how long have you been having this problem?
Just like two months.
Bro, what the fuck?
When did you...
I could fix this.
Yeah, why fix when can buy?
No!
Yeah, that's my motto.
That's crazy.
That's what I do.
Exactly.
That's what you do.
Why fix when I can just buy?
Because I can fix it.
And I can't buy it.
That's so much work.
Monetarily wise?
Yeah.
I guess I can buy it.
Yeah!
But then I'll just change the switch immediately.
You're not even... yeah, you can sell the old one.
Yeah.
I'm free love.
Signed.
Yeah, see?
Oh my god, you just...
You can do that now.
You can auction off your...
Wait!
You could!
You sign the mouse and then you auction it off.
I could.
But like, I do have to point out the disclaimer.
It doesn't come with my skills.
I mean, I don't think that's what they want from them.
I mean, you don't know my fans.
I think other stuff is gonna be done.
No, no, no.
I think other stuff is gonna be done with your mouse.
They'll be desperate.
Ewww!
What do you mean, eww?
It's like a collection.
Eww!
Yeah, it comes with the gamer sweat.
What skills?
Indeed, I don't have one.
The gamer sweat.
Yeah, it just comes with my sweat.
Yeah, and then...
Oh yeah, they like that.
What the fuck?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
What the hell?
That sounds like they're not buying it for the skills.
Put the mouse in the what?
The jar?
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, but Tengen, think about the amount of money you'll get.
Think about it.
No.
You know it's tempting.
You should auction it off.
And then if it's signed too.
What the fuck?
A mouse smitten me!
I'm just helping Tengen make money.
What do you mean?
Dude!
Wait, what the fuck?
Bro, this guy...
I think this guy's special.
Did you just go around and call people special?
No, you should've seen what I just saw.
Like...
Okay.
You should've seen what I saw.
You literally stood there to get shot at.
For like at least five seconds.
They're like right here.
He's definitely special.
What?
I'm trying to figure out...
Do you know where they are?
Like below me?
Hey.
Are we fine?
Ha!
Oh, you'll be fine?
Oh, you got them.
Where's his teammate though?
I'm in the sky waiting.
Surely.
Does he have heavy ammo?
Is this a special guy?
Guy I almost killed?
No.
Probably.
No, it's not.
Let me know you're fine.
Oh, wait, I hear him.
Let me know you guys find heavy ammo.
Oh, there he is.
Oh.
Was that the special kid?
What did he do?
What happened?
What the fuck did he do?
Okay, he blasted the whole Spitfire at me and didn't hit a single one.
Oh.
I am like shotgun range man.
That might have been him.
I told you.
He's special.
Oh.
Oh, wait, wait.
To my right, I see the sniper.
Oh, wait, he's actually hitting you.
Nice scream.
Please stop.
I'm scared.
Okay, Valkyrie.
Okay.
I don't know where his teammates are.
Like, this guy is definitely...
Wait, I'm getting shot from a second cross.
I'm getting shot from a cross.
Am I right?
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Yeah, this feels like...
This feels like Singapore servers.
The...
The different ranges of fucking skills in this lobby.
Yeah.
This is how it goes down here.
The wild west, that's for sure.
I saw the Valk...
I saw the Valk literally just like fucking...
like M1 flew to my face.
And I'm like, okay.
I mean, okay.
That's the play.
I'm gonna fucking grab the...
armor shit.
I wanna have that care package.
That next lifeline care package.
Okay.
Another squad, what?
Is there... oh, the...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, two golden triple taking one squad.
I don't get what they're doing, but hey.
Where are they?
Where are they, Tengen?
It's King's Canyon, I'm not sure.
Tengen!
Where are they?
Over there.
Where's there?
There.
Wait, are they actually?
Wait, oh my god, they are!
What the fuck?
How did you see it?
Oh, he's fucking dead.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Get outta there, man.
Get outta there.
Goodbye.
Get outta there, bro.
Bro, get outta there.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
I'm meeting the lifeline.
Get outta there.
I think he also is a little special too.
Oh, you saw that, no?
Yep.
Take it, take a sip.
Don't take a sip, don't take a sip, don't take a sip!
Shit, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead!
Cover me, cover me!
What do you mean?
No!
I can't believe you guys just let them do that to me.
That's fucked up.
Okay, Tengen, do not... Tengen, no!
Oh, he's so low!
What is he doing?
Bro, I hit two shots!
Oh no.
Legit, I hit two shots.
They rez, they rez.
Oh no, they rez.
I hear her, the rez.
Oh my god, he's jumping over.
He's on the roof, he's spiderman-ing.
Oh crap.
He's on the roof, Tengen!
Oh my god, the bloodhound's coming over too!
Okay, you gotta make sure the lifeline doesn't rez him.
You gotta heal, you gotta heal.
Where is my friend?
He's over there, he's over there!
I'm watching!
What is he doing?
Shoot!
I'm watching, I'm watching!
Oh my god, the lifeline's rez-ing!
The lifeline's rez-ing!
Bro, where is my friend?
Bro, he's special, okay?
He missed?
Okay...
You should really...
Oh no.
I'm spraying left and right for you.
Oh my...
He's dead, he's dead, he's dead!
Okay.
I have...
I have... I fucked up.
I... I... I...
Okay, I would admit... I have aneurysm.
I would admit I did do something a little special today.
I'm gonna have a stroke.
I swear, I blasted like three mags to people, two people are low, my friend's behind just charging himself.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
That was...
Uh...
Oh, we have a bot.
Oh, it's okay, we...
It's okay.
I just... I got a little bit too...
You know what?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna actually... I'm gonna play the game.
You're gonna actually...
You're gonna actually play the game!
No way.
I've been autopiloting as well the whole time.
Oh man.
I'm gonna actually play the game this time.
She's actually playing.
Oh my god, this is it.
There's no way.
This is it.
I didn't know you played Bangalore.
Oh my god, really?
Oh yeah, you just met me so you don't know.
Right.
Yeah.
You just found out.
Don't worry, I'm gonna show you.
Yeah, what do you play?
Dungeon?
What do I play?
Yeah, who do you main?
Hmm...
Shit, who did I main?
I just fail.
I fail.
I'll be honest.
I have no...
boundaries of who to play and what to play.
Really?
Yeah.
And you used to play something before?
What was it?
You have like...
Huh.
You used to play...
You mentioned it before to me when we met like a couple of days ago.
Was it Newcastle?
Yeah, sure.
Oh my god.
There's 20 people on me.
Yeah, because you have a goddamn trail on your ass.
You thought there's 20 people on me.
Oh my god.
That's a whole ass...
I told you!
There's 20 people on my ass!
Oh my god.
Okay, I am okay.
Wait, what?
I can't click.
Behind you!
There's another guy to our right as well.
I'm just gonna walk away.
But you can rush me against this door.
It'll be safe.
Where are you?
Right here?
Wait, it's okay.
Our guys can rush me.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's more.
Yeah, our guys...
No.
Oh no.
I'm like... The door is...
No!
There's more people!
Bro, I fucking...
No!
I said there's a lot!
Why did we land here?
You!
I was not jumpmaster!
Oh yeah, you was not.
You got this.
Where is he?
Right there.
Okay.
Okay, they're fighting each other.
They're fighting each other.
No way!
You're not doing this.
Are you?
No!
Oh my god.
Oh god.
No!
He can't... No!
Swap!
Oh my god!
Bro!
I'm having that moment!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Bro, we win!
Okay, that was pretty game-y though.
Dude.
That was pretty game-y.
Yeah, that is awesome.
That was sick.
Honestly, that was clean.
But the timing could not have been better but that got out.
That was pretty clean.
That was pretty fucking clean.
I hit all those shots that I needed to hit there.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
That was awesome.
Yeah, that was pretty clean.
Spitfire.
If only our fucking...
If our guy still had his shield, I think I could have clutched it.
But the Rampart shit fucked him up.
The Rampart shit was too good.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We can't end until we win, Tenjin.
We're gonna be here forever.
We're ending?
Nah.
What's that?
Funny word.
We don't end until I win.
Alright, let's be serious.
Oh, now you wanna be serious.
Wow.
Alright, here we go.
I told you I was playing for real.
Yeah, we're playing for real now.
Yeah, I told you guys.
We're playing for real.
For real, for reals.
Yeah.
We're gamers.
That boy is ready to sleep, to be fair.
He like, before we started this stream, he was like, Oh man, my fucking stomach.
Yeah.
I needed to shit.
He drank coffee before the stream, guys.
He did.
I stayed up from 2.
You still drinking?
No.
I'm good.
I'm drinking water.
Okay.
Yeah, he stayed.
He like, woke up the wrong time.
Even though I reminded him the time.
Like, and he saw my schedule.
And he still forgot the actual time.
Oh.
No, my game crashed!
No!
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
Please keep me alive.
Keep me alive.
Yes, you can.
No, it's not that bad.
I swear it's not that bad.
I swear.
We'll be okay.
Am I dead?
No.
Okay.
Just keep going.
Keep guard.
They won't expect it because I'm standing still.
So it's like I'm part of the nature.
You're not gonna make any noises, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hear you.
It's part of the nature.
Okay, please tell me I'm still alive, Tangent.
You are.
Okay.
I'm in.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
I am safe.
Holy shit.
How did you get me all the way here?
There's a whole team inside of you.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
Don't worry.
Oh, maybe you worry a little bit.
Wait, there's another team!
Oh my god!
I'm dead.
There's already another team.
Look, man.
We're pretty much f'd.
Oh, no.
I'm still okay.
They're not gonna look here.
You're good, right?
Yeah, I'm good.
I'm good.
No, I'm not because there's two thieves.
I'm okay.
They're like on the wall right now.
On the roof.
I don't know.
See, I told you I'm okay.
Oh, you're so not okay, Tangent.
Oh, I'm dead.
You are so f'd.
Keep crawling.
You got this.
Yeah, I told you.
Keep crawling.
You'll be alright.
No.
No!
What?
Who are you?
You!
Give us smoke.
No.
Like, literally, I'm one hit.
Get out of here.
Okay.
I have ult.
What the f'k are these people?
Oh, my God.
Where did these guys come from?
Okay.
It's definitely not okay.
I was not okay.
How did your game go?
I don't know.
I got like some weird error code.
I didn't even read it fully.
Because I was like, what the f'k is this error code?
It's the weirdest sh'it.
Okay.
There was like four f'ing teams here.
There was so...
Oh, my God.
There is like four...
It's okay.
The guy that killed me died.
That's all that matters.
They don't deserve it.
I hope...
They don't deserve anything.
Paid actor.
Oh, my God.
Literally came out of f'ing nowhere.
What is that Horizon doing?
Or Talos?
What is happening with this team?
The hell?
I thought you were gonna focus up.
What happened?
You crashed?
Okay.
I crashed, but I was still alive.
I wanted to push someone.
And then my game crashed.
Wait.
You were crashed too?
No.
I'm good.
I was gonna say.
This time.
Surely.
There's no way.
There's no f'ing way.
I just slapped myself.
If we lose...
I don't know why, but hey.
If we don't win this next game...
Stay on me.
I'm the champion.
I'll superchat Tenjin.
Wait.
No.
Because then you wanna lose.
I won't.
Trust.
If we win this game...
I'll superchat Tenjin.
What?
Nah.
You can't do this to me.
Why are you giving me pressure?
And expectations.
Which I never really had.
I can do something really f'ed up.
I can be like...
The superchat starts at 500...
Not 500.
100.
And then every loss, it loses $10.
What?
Who are you?
Mr. Beast?
You Mr. Beast era?
We double or nothing.
But instead of giving money...
I take it away.
Where are they?
They're in this building.
Oh.
I see them.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I got shot by a...
Good luck Tenjin.
Mr. Beast.
Tenjin.
Good luck.
Think about it.
Think about the money.
Yeah.
He's rising in front of you.
Okay.
But now you have to win.
We have to win this as a duo now.
What?
No.
It's still 100.
It's still one akka.
Where are the Doki Beast funds?
Doki Beast funds.
I like how someone's like throwing to pay less.
That wasn't throwing.
They're just throwing in the...
He's throwing in a pot.
I didn't expect to get shot by three fucking people.
Like what the fuck?
How do you expect me to live?
I was like what the fuck?
I mean I don't even know what our teammate was doing.
Honestly it's true.
I don't know either.
Like they just waited there.
Oh okay.
Oh I like it.
Every kill gets $10.
Assists don't count.
Someone's flying here.
Let's go.
Oh shit.
Already?
Oh he's serious now.
Lifeline's on you.
Oh my god.
No he's one.
Oh he's resing.
Below you.
Yeah well I can't do anything can I?
Oh no.
No.
Pension I think you should just leave.
I don't know man.
Oh.
He's running out.
Over here on me.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
The heck?
Alright.
Man.
Man where is our trio?
I don't know bro.
Okay.
I won't throw this time.
Oh this is.
You.
Chris you fucking dick.
That's my friend.
Your friend does not want you to have an arca.
Bro.
Bro you fucking.
You're a bitch.
Chris you fuck.
It's arca super.
You.
You sick fuck.
I swear to god you sick fuck.
You fucking fuck.
You sick fuck.
Oh my god.
Your friend was like no arca super for you.
Crazy.
That's actually like crazy.
That's crazy.
That's a bro right there.
That's a.
Oh.
That son of a bitch.
Bro cost him ten dollars.
.
Okay now he's got ninety dollars.
But every kill is at ten dollars.
Every kill is ten dollars.
Oh my god I feel like Mr. Beast right now.
I am Mr. Beast.
The dokey beast.
Guys I'm gonna like.
If I.
Stradded you on an island would you do it?
Bro is.
Bro is sniping us and trying to be in the same party as us.
Nah bro.
Hell.
You have betrayed me.
You're like bro I need this.
I shall take your mod title.
Yeah remove his mod title.
I did.
Bro you fucking took your ten dollars.
You fucking took your ten dollars.
That's crazy.
That's fucked up bro.
We're stealing.
Isn't he also indo?
Yeah he is.
Damn.
You're stealing it from a fellow.
A fellow.
Indonesian.
Bro you.
First you steal my money.
And I never had rights to begin with.
That was my one way ticket to having rights man.
How dare you.
Damn.
That's fucked up bro.
That's fucked up man.
Bro took the rights.
He's like if I can't be on your team.
Then you don't deserve my.
Damn it.
Hell.
Bro is praying for my downfall.
I'm gonna check out the map room.
Wait there's people here.
Wait is there?
No I was lying.
We could scan the radar.
Yeah I was lying.
I was just paranoid.
That's it.
See I'm gonna grab.
Oh no.
Oh no I'm seeing things.
Oh.
I'm not even here.
I've been.
This has been the solo stream.
I actually.
Tengiz my secret account.
Imaginary friend.
Someone scanned us just now.
They're here.
Don't worry I'm serious now.
They know I'm literally right here.
Got one.
Oh shit.
Wow ever since I gave him an incentive.
He's actually killing everybody.
That's actually crazy.
Where is his teammate?
Did you get another one?
Oh my god.
Oh he's behind.
Let him rez.
Wait where?
Okay he doesn't rez me.
I don't know where he's going.
It's fine.
He's almost dead.
He's not rezzing you?
No.
There's a $10 for you.
There.
Oh he's a YouTuber.
No wonder he's trying to get clips.
Yeah he's trying to get clips bro.
Yeah he's trying to get clips for his.
Promoting channel.
Yeah yeah yeah.
We should take the clips away from him.
He doesn't deserve it.
Yeah we're also growing streamers.
You should ask him.
Yo you want $10?
Yeah.
Just pay him off.
You want $5?
Okay.
We can split this off man.
You want $10 and ruin Tenjin's game again?
So he loses another $10.
Ail.
It's like that.
You remember that story of that parent that like paid like an online bounty hunter?
And where like that guy like he hired somebody to like purposely assassinate his son's character.
And so he'll like stop playing video games.
Oh man.
That's gonna be me.
What?
Dude.
Okay.
He's just trying to be thoughtful.
And I'll be like red purposely ruined.
Let's see.
He's trying to be thoughtful.
What am I gonna do with this?
Well you never heard of that story before?
I have.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
I just don't want you to know that.
That's gonna be me.
To me?
Yeah.
What's your friend's name?
Classy?
Fucking...
What is he?
Chris.
Chris?
Okay.
Chris.
Chris are you in this game?
Chris you want $10?
You want $10?
From 10 to his balance?
He said nah.
Nah.
He'll do it for free.
No cause he'll do it for free.
I'm chilling.
He doesn't need the $10.
He'll do it for free.
The hell.
Bro's chilling he says.
Bro's fucked up.
He literally killed you for free.
He didn't even want it.
He had no purpose.
No reason.
No reason to be there.
Oh he's not in the game.
No he's not in the game.
If he was he'd be ready.
He probably would.
I could tell.
There should be a team in front of us.
I saw like from your scan.
Or from Red's scan.
Oh in front of us.
Oh there they are.
How we doing this?
I don't know.
It's your $10.
What?
Oh yeah.
I'm getting paid.
Yeah.
That was our deal.
Oh I got one of those kills.
Oh they're wiped.
Is that fully wiped?
Oh we did it.
Nice.
Easiest $10 of your life.
That's a whole lot.
I ulted for nothing.
Yeah but think about that $10 though.
Think of that Mr. Deest dollars.
Legit $10?
Yeah.
That's like 3 weeks.
Oh true.
That's actually true.
That's 3 weeks of food.
Wait really?
If you find your place right.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Other than I guess like the only trade off is that like customs f***ing suck.
Yeah well.
You know.
I'm $10 richer.
I can only say that.
Yeah only if you win this game though.
What?
Yeah.
It applies to your winning the game.
What?
20 bomb.
20 bomb plus the win.
Alright grab some armor.
$10 is $10.
Honestly yeah.
Weather kinda suck.
Is the weather suck?
Why?
It's hot.
It's been like 40 degrees lately.
I mean that's Asia in general though.
Is that just Asia?
They don't see us.
Okay now they might know.
Now they definitely know.
They still have net.
No no no.
Yeah I'm gonna look over them and they're gonna f***ing look.
Okay now they know.
Okay.
They have to know.
They definitely know.
What?
How is that not a baby?
Oh my god dude this guy's a baby.
This guy's actually a baby.
Holy shit that guy's a baby.
There's no way.
We just killed a child.
Oh my god we actually killed a child.
Where's his teammate?
In the game.
Yeah yeah yeah.
My lawyer advises me.
Nice.
I got the kill.
In the game.
Yeah yeah in the game.
We don't want a repeat.
Okay but did you see that bloodhound?
He was so confused.
Woah!
Woah woah woah.
I'm gonna heal real fast.
To my left.
Why?
Don't leave.
Where did he go?
Oh there he is.
Wait he didn't get hit?
He's so low!
Knocked him.
Where's his teammate?
Bye!
Give me your loot.
You'll be fine right?
Surely.
Oh no there's another team.
There's another team?
Oh wait there's another team above.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I'm bailing.
Where's the other?
Where's his teammate then?
Shit!
They're scared.
Wait I hear him.
To my left.
Yeah yeah yeah.
He's in here.
He's in there.
He went inside.
I didn't get him.
I'm just gonna loot this.
Woah!
Red armor?
I'm gonna...
bat?
Don't worry I got you.
I'm gonna...
Nice!
They have to come to us.
This team has to come to us.
Hold on.
Four seconds.
Oh man they're...
Yeah they're rolling down.
They're rolling down.
I'm watching.
You alright?
I'm just holding them.
Where they at?
My ping.
On me?
Behind this rock?
Yeah.
Wait.
That's like a solo.
Hiding.
There's a solo right there.
Yeah!
No no no no no!
No!
Wait that's not even a solo!
You want that.
Wait where did he go?
Did someone rotate this?
Yeah he did.
No way.
No way!
No kill for you!
No way they rotated that.
That's crazy.
What the fuck!
Alright.
One last team.
One last team huh?
Wouldn't it be funny if that one team killed us?
That would be so funny.
Tenzin it would be so fucking funny.
You know it.
Wait.
That's open.
Yeah.
Friggin shot by it.
Oh my god!
Would it be funny if I just throw that right now?
Oh, it's over there.
Woah, where am I getting shot from?
I swear.
What are you doing something stupid?
It's like they're hitting me mid-airs.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
I knocked one.
Where's his teammate?
Wait, his teammate's so far.
They made a nexus.
Oh!
That's dumb.
Tengen, the last kill!
Tengen!
Man, they went by a nexus?
That's annoying.
Holy shit, they made a nexus to go back.
Unlucky Tengen, you had...
Unlucky.
That's crazy.
But you got that... you got...
Okay, but you didn't get other kills.
Okay, that was 90 for the win.
And... how much?
How much?
Woah, you got 7 kills?
Bro, Red Sea.
Red Sea, delete your YouTube channel, Red Sea.
That's 160!
160!
What?
Yeah, the 90 on top.
Also, Red Sea, I'm joking.
Don't delete your YouTube channel.
But like...
But like... bro, it's a little embarrassing, bro.
A win?
Yeah, you got a win!
No way.
You did it!
How do you feel?
I can buy more cigarettes.
I'm kidding.
I'm joking.
Holy shit.
I have pocket money, bro.
That's...
God, see...
I swear to God.
No, dude.
I swear to fucking God, man.
I swear to God.
Okay.
What?
Oh yeah, I forgot.
It's not a cigarette.
I forgot.
I'm not using Super Chat.
We don't want...
You forgot.
YouTube should not be taking this cut.
No!
Oh yeah, YouTube takes a cut.
I forgot about that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Holy shit.
That's why I was like...
That is so true.
You're not taking attention cigarette money.
You're not...
I can't...
Oh, man.
See, that's not so hard.
Nah.
It's not so...
It's an easy game.
See, look at that.
Like, if you... I think if you didn't get Streams Night by your friend, you could have won the last game.
I think 100%.
Not really.
There's two... Oh, no.
There you go.
Easy.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, look, that's me!
Not cigarette money.
That's me.
It could be.
Thanks for the...
It could be a cigarette money.
Thanks for the... Thanks for the boost, man.
You know how they're like, here's my PayPal.
Even though I did more damage there.
Wow.
Thank you, Doki Beast.
Oh, my God.
I'm surprised you didn't double or nothing.
Give it to the next guy.
Give it to the next guy?
Nah, nah, nah.
If I have some fuel left, maybe...
Doki Beast.
Doki Beast is here.
Don't worry, guys.
Oh, you wanna be my... Who are the... Who is like that... The Mr. Beast people?
Like, the guy that's always sticking around with Mr. Beast?
His gang.
Yeah, his gang.
Who is this?
Are you like my shadow?
Why is there a gif in the middle?
What the fu... Oh, my God.
I see.
What is there... Oh, so what?
Why is she that funny?
I was like, why is there a gif?
A single gif in the middle?
The Indonesian flag.
Yeah, you wanna be my... You can be my... Do you wanna be my Carl or Chandler?
Yeah.
Who do you wanna be?
I can be your Chandler.
You wanna be my Chandler?
Okay.
This is Chandler Tengen.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna be the VTuber Mr. Beast here.
GG's, man.
I had a great time, though.
GG's.
We're gonna...
Yes.
I played Defiant next week.
Yeah.
That's my ex-Defiant.
Yeah, ex-Defiant next week.
We're going to... guys, next week...
Gather people if you want.
Oh, hell yeah.
Let's do it.
Wait.
How many people do we need?
I'm not sure.
How much is a full party for?
I don't fucking know.
I haven't touched that game yet.
I'll ask around.
All right.
Yeah, I'm down.
I'm down.
GG's, man.
I have a try-hard friend there for some reason.
Oh, yeah.
People are gonna be so...
Kaz.
Kaz is my brother's name.
I swear if that's actually my little brother donating...
Oh, no, no.
That's a...
What the fuck is he doing?
That's a dragoon.
Kaz is my little bro's name, by the way.
Oh, my God.
Kaz.
You're secretly his little brother?
I didn't realize that.
Who would have thought?
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
Kaz was secretly...
Kaz?
...sincerely the little brother.
The little dragoon?
Yeah, of course.
No way.
That's...
You know the allowance you gave your little brother?
It all went back to me.
I see.
That's why I'm giving it back.
Giving it back all the time.
This whole time.
No way.
Yeah, damn right.
Oh, bless you.
GG's, though.
Have a great time.
GG's.
I'm gonna go talk to my dragoons now.
Hope you guys enjoyed us playing together for the very first time on stream.
For the very first time.
Yeah, very first time.
Once again, very first time.
We haven't met until...
I had a very good impression.
Yeah.
Very good impression.
It's not like I...
I found this person on, like, Fiverr to make me...
Totally not Pryp.
I put myself on Craigslist to beat something.
Yeah, on Craigslist.
And I need, like, meet a collab partner.
Meet a collab partner who's good at, like, FPS games.
And also to make me look... but not good enough so that I can look good.
Yeah,
what is it, Ten?
What do you wanna say?
But obviously now we didn't do that.
No, I'm having a heart attack.
Guys, we didn't do that, guys.
Obviously.
Like, he's a real person.
He's a real person.
I am.
I'm not a paid actor.
Don't worry.
He's not a paid actor, guys.
Totally not behind in contract to say this.
When I sent him that $160, we did not plan this, guys.
Because it was not because that $160 was, like, part of his, like, hourly wage for, like, playing with me.
It was a real challenge, guys.
A very real challenge.
A real challenge.
My pits are sweating.
Any final words, Tenjin, before I talk to my dragoons and you talk to your Anjings?
Thank you.
And honestly, I'm actually... what do you call it?
I'm in a rush right now.
Oh, wait.
Why?
Because I have to head to a hospital.
Wait, what?
My grandfather is going through a surgery.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Yeah, fuck!
Go do that!
Go!
What the fuck!
Yeah, go freaking do it!
What are you doing here?
An hour later probably, yeah.
Alright, GG man!
GG!
Alright, I'll see you dude.
See you next week.
Will do.
Bye!
Oh my god!
What the fuck!
That went too real!
I hope like, yeah well...
He said it's in an hour so he'll be there in like...
He says plenty of time to go to the hospital.
But yeah, it was great!
Connecting with Tengen.
Let me swap real quick.
Where's my chatting screen?
There we go.
Add a...
Great time.
Um, hanging out with Tengen today.
Um...
And just talking about like...
The most random shit.
And just fucking around.
Like he's a real homie.
He's a real homie slash bro.
So, just felt like, you know...
Just talk about the fucking craziest shit.
And just having fun time.
Just playing...
Would you hire him again?
He's a real friend.
He's a real person.
I did not hire him off of Fiverr.
And paid him a salary.
To make me look good, guys.
He's real!
None of it was scripted!
I swear!
All of it was...
Real!
Anyway guys...
Um...
It was a great time.
I didn't think I was gonna play Rust.
For so long.
But I actually enjoyed the roleplaying.
And like...
It was actually funny.
Willnef actually followed me back on Twitter.
Which I thought was funny.
Which I thought was really nice.
Because I didn't think he would...
He's also a pretty big streamer.
So I thought it was really nice that...
Willnef followed me back.
For those who don't know who he was...
In Rust.
He was like...
He was uncle.
The uncle Billy.
So...
Yeah, uncle baby Billy.
Um...
So that was like...
A really fun time.
And...
Um...
And I had a great time on both Rust and Apex today.
I think tomorrow is a rest day for me.
Right?
Tomorrow is a... Yes!
Okay.
Thank God.
Because I really need the rest right now.
I'm so tired.
The double streams...
Made me so tired.
So I'm like... Oh thank God.
It's a rest day.
Oh thank God.
Because I was like...
Oh man.
I don't think I have the energy...
For tomorrow.
I don't...
I don't think I have the fucking...
Energy.
Um...
Yes everybody.
It was such a fun time.
It was actually really fun.
I was honestly so nervous.
Uh...
So nervous today in Rust.
And um... I like that...
Um...
I... I'm happy that I was able to have...
Like such a fun experience.
Um...
In Rust with everybody and just like...
Talking to... Making like new friends and stuff.
And roleplaying.
Because I'm always scared of roleplaying.
Because I'm very...
Scared of like...
I feel like I'm not a very good roleplayer.
So like I'm always super scared about roleplaying.
Just because I don't think I'm good at roleplaying.
So I'm glad that like...
I'm glad...
That I was able to...
To our...
Like you know... Make it entertaining for people.
And had like really good roleplayers.
To like...
Um...
To like... Um...
Bounce off on.
Um... I... It was crazy.
Okay so I actually knew about the whole...
The Blood God shit.
Like because I remember...
I used to watch like...
Uh... I remember I watched the very first...
Rust Arc.
So the very very first Rust Arc...
With like...
When the Blood God thing first started.
Uh...
Like... I think like two years ago.
Um...
Two years ago.
Like the very first time...
The Blood God thing started.
Two years ago.
And I used to watch that.
I remember watching that too.
On stream.
It's a consistent lore.
Yeah it's not like this is new.
So... Um...
So like...
I was so...
Yeah it was during the pandemic.
So when the fact that I was able to like...
Be a part of it.
Cause this was like...
Pre... Like you know...
Before I was like a streamer thing.
Before I was like a streamer.
I remember watching shit like that.
Like watching it.
It wasn't even two years.
Was it three years ago?
Holy shit that was so long ago.
Like I think it was like three...
Three plus years ago.
When the Blood God thing first started.
And the fact that...
Like I got to be part of it now.
It was four years ago?
Oh my god!
Anyway...
Like I said that I got a chance to actually be part...
Of the...
Blood God cult.
Something I watched four years ago.
When I was like a nobody.
And then like four years later.
I actually got to meet Will Neff.
And like actually got to like...
RP and join the cult.
And everything.
Oh my god.
Like that shit was...
That shit blew my mind.
Like I was you know...
Like roleplaying as like super gullible and oblivious.
And stuff like that.
Cause I didn't you know...
For the RP's sake.
And...
And it was just... It was crazy.
I thought it was like crazy.
To be able to RP stuff like that.
For people that like I used to watch...
Four plus years ago.
And like also interact with like...
You were acting?
Okay maybe it was like...
Half acting.
Okay.
Um...
Yeah.
So it was pretty fun.
I had a great time playing...
Rest and I'm really happy that Gumi...
Gave her time to...
Give me a tour.
You know?
Give me a tour and like introduce me to some people.
And like...
Like you know start the roleplay stuff.
And everything.
So yeah.
I had a great time.
Um...
And a great time...
Playing with Tenjin today.
And just like...
Hang out with Tenjin.
And uh...
You know like we've actually...
We've actually uh...
Hanged out a lot off stream.
With like gaming and stuff.
Like Apex and...
Stuff like that.
And just chatting.
So like it was great to be able to...
Hang out with him on stream.
And being able to just...
You know...
Like just like fuck around.
And stuff on stream.
And having guys watch too.
So it was great.
I had a great time.
And uh...
Anyway guys.
I'm gonna call it here today.
Thank you everybody for the super chats.
And you know...
And the subs.
Cause I was gonna say I might read some super chats.
But um...
I realized I haven't had dinner yet.
And it's 8pm.
So I should order something before...
I should order something before like...
Restaurants start closing.
So I'm gonna call it here everybody.
As always everyone stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.